you impressed me you really did
but let's get to work something cool you
got him 47
marcus stuyvesant won't be a problem
anymore
the first big game of 2021 is hitman 3.
it's coming a lot sooner than i expected
and me and phil we've got a chance to
check out the game a little early a
preview build and we're just gonna
talk about how we feel about it so far
uh thanks for joining me phil yeah
thanks
i had a pretty good time with it how
about you i had a pretty good time with
it i think
the the biggest question i would want to
know going in is like
uh as the third game in the hitman
trilogy like what are they bringing new
to the table
like what's what's different like how
are they you know evolving it
and i would say not all that much
mechanically it's very much more hitman
that's not a bad thing but i i think
that's sort of worth um
worth knowing going in that like you're
not gonna get a drastically like
enhanced
like hitman 2 i would say was more
incremental as well but it did have a
couple of
significant additions uh they added like
social stealth where you could blend
into crowds they improved the camera
work
uh and by that i mean like the literal
like security cameras um right
not the camera and uh they also added
like
workable mirrors uh and those were
subtle changes but they were
noteworthy this game i didn't really
notice anything
all that new where it's new is more
in you know the brand new levels and
sort of like setups they give you
right my sense of it was that maybe
these levels
are a little bigger a little more
intricate potentially especially the
second one we
um can't start any video of that but we
might talk about a little bit
this game is pulling in both hitman 1
and hitman 2. all those missions
will be available if you own them
already or you know if you haven't
jumped on hitman before this you can
pull them into this one package
in that sense like it feels like this is
all one big game it can't really change
all that much
um it is still really good like hitman
one and two are
great i had a great time i've always had
a great time with him yeah
and so more hitman is cool and they're
it's a really
inventive couple of new levels so it has
that going for it
it's not changing anything drastically
but it's a lot of fun i had a
really good time yeah yeah so yeah the
first level is is dubai
which um it's kind of what they showed
in the reveal trailer for the game
and it is you described as like they
watched mission impossible and they were
like let's do that
which is always what i love about hitman
is when you can tell they like watch
something
um the second level which is like in a
mansion uh has like a murder mystery and
you're like oh they watched knives out
yeah it's like an ag agatha christie
novel
exactly but also hitman is happening in
the background yeah
the dubai levels is good it reminds me a
lot of the paris level
in the first hitman hitman 2016 first
hit man
um where uh it's like a party set up but
then
you kind of have the ability to go like
behind the scenes and sort of like
navigate like well this is where
you know the staff hangs out and this is
where the janitors are
except because you're on a giant
skyscraper in dubai they add this
element where you can kind of like
uh get outside the building and you're
kind of like shimming up poles and stuff
like that
and that's a lot of fun it's definitely
one of the levels where
the fun of it is like just figuring out
the layout and like where everything
kind of connects and knowing like okay
this shortcut will lead to here and and
kind of puzzling out how everything fits
together
yeah it's a really like dense maze like
level which i really enjoyed about it's
also really vertical
any any given floor is actually pretty
small and there there are a lot of like
big open rooms big atriums
but um you're going upstairs a lot
you're trying to find other ways of
getting you know like
like you said in the background behind
the scenes areas in the security
wing or like back where the catering is
happening and stuff like that and
they're all like
stacked up on each other weird so it's
it's
interesting trying to find your way
around um
and that that's like the toughest part
is like
um i felt like not even just having the
right disguise but
knowing what the hell area i was
supposed to be in
with this certain outfit so um i had i
had a good time with that
yeah and i would say the other thing
that i i do feel like they've been
improving on
is so hitman always has like story
opportunities where they're kind of like
you can
technically beat the mission any way you
want but they they offer these like
little story vignettes with dialogue
that are kind of meant to like
lead you to a very specific kill we both
did this one where
you uh basically have to like pretend to
be a
different assassin uh that like one of
your targets is trying to hire
so you can like get a meeting with him
but to do it they want to give you like
a test
and so you have to like take out this
journalist i hear you're looking for
information oh really okay
you know what's happening upstairs i
know more than you could imagine
and what i liked about it was it
actually added a little bit of variety
where
you can choose to you can like actually
go kill
the uh the reporter if you want but you
can also like
you know lead him and like knock him out
and like make him just look like he's
dead so like i
it's small it's not like you know
branching narrative but
i i like that there's like they're
adding a little bit of variety into like
how you approach some of these story
stuff
and then the second one uh with the
murder mystery also does that as well
to even more extreme i'm i'm bummed we
can't like show more of it because that
like
is you you basically like pretend to be
a detective and
have to solve a murder mystery maybe the
coolest thing hitman's done
it's such a good it's so good you can
catch a little more of our preview
um on gamespot.com i'm going to write an
article about that
having done it yet but i will um and
yeah it's mostly going to focus on the
murder mystery because like
i had a great time with that um that
section of it it was
it's like playing a different game for a
bit but also you're always thinking
about
how to do the hitman part the whole time
and it's really good it's like it's
great how involved it is they really uh
went all out on that murder mystery
storyline it's pretty good
that that is the most exciting and i'm
hoping
some of the other levels maybe get into
that too where like
yeah it kind of like derails you it
feels like that's them
getting more experimental where like
you're with like mechanics and story
lines and
playing that just made me like super
excited for their uh their double 07
game they're working on yeah like okay
like this is them like using these
mechanics in different ways
other than to just kill people right
even though i do think the game
maybe mechanically isn't anything all
new i still think they're like top of
their form when it comes to just like
level design and like creative ways to
like kill people and solutions like i
it's still like talk to your hitman so
like
you know if you're like us and you loved
those other games like you're going to
have a i think you're going to have a
good time with it
yeah i think so too and it really feels
like even the dubai level like
dubai is doing it more i think with
level design than
um where the second level is doing it
more with like
the characters and the the clockwork of
it but
it's still like inventive and cool in a
different way and
there are you know of course a number of
ways you can solve it and i didn't get
into
any of the 40 challenges or whatever but
i'm sure they get ridiculous
as well i had a good time just uh just
doing like
the one main story mission which is like
that
feels like the canonical one basically
you sneak into the server room
botch hacking the computer get security
guys coming after you d were you able to
hide from those guys i couldn't hide
them i just
i was able to hide a lot of them i just
didn't mind one of the little servers i
just like waited for them to
i did that poorly i guess so
yeah i ended up just like wailing on
them all and then hiding in a cabinet
for a long time
and like switching disguises two more
times
finally clearing the area and then
pulling it off where you have to like
draw both the targets for that level
into a secret meeting
yeah and then i just shot him in the
back of the head and it was great
kyle ingram finally gets what he
deserves
good rhythms it's more hitman and like
right i think that's
that's not gonna blow anyone's socks off
but i think you know as we've mentioned
if
if you love hitman it's it's gonna be
great i think you're gonna have a good
time with it
there's a couple i know there's a couple
of big things that they're adding to the
game that we didn't get to check out one
was
ray tracing which is coming post-launch
so we didn't get to see
that um i'm kind of curious how that
like changes the the look because hitman
levels i mean are gorgeous
so like ray tracing could look
absolutely beautiful
yeah that's the other thing about that
dubai level is like with ray tracing
it's gonna look crazy
it looks great already there's a moment
where they like
where you go up to like the top uh and
like the camera like pans out to like
show
and it's like the it's this beautiful
looking like the floor has like all
these reflections and there's a pool of
water and you can tell
that's supposed to be like the ray
tracing moment you know
um but then the other big thing that i'm
very excited about um
is the vr mode that they're adding right
but that's only playstation
unfortunately i don't have a playstation
vr so yeah me neither i'm
kind of bummed i i'm gonna have to
remedy that situation find a way to
because uh that looks insane and i'm so
curious about that i feel like that's
gonna be the big thing
um well phyllis you mentioned you have a
written preview over on gamespot uh
talking more about the
uh murder murder mystery level uh and
all that goodness to go check that out
uh and of course we have plenty of other
hitman stuff i think we have like a cool
little montage
uh put together showing off some fun
kills and of course the game is coming
out real soon so make sure to stay
tuned to gamespot because we'll have a
full review and coverage of the game
hopefully vr too yeah
[Music]
you